to present the awards for art direction
and set direction we have a well
decorated young lady named tina louise
from god's little acre and her certainly
is a young man named Tony Randall whose
last job was let's make love with
Marilyn Monroe and his mother wanted him
to be President and waste all that time
in a rocking chair ladies and gentlemen
Tina Louise and Tony Randall
Tony will you read the first nomination
certainly Tina Louise is nominated to go
out with Tony Randall after the show
tonight and tests his rocking chair I
get dizzy scared yeah yeah yes read the
nominee those nominated for best
achievement in art direction and set
decoration for a black and white
reduction are the apartment art
direction by Alexander trow no set
decoration by Edward G Boyle the facts
of life art direction by Joseph
Macmillan Johnson and Kenneth a real set
decoration by Ross down-cycle art
direction by Joseph Hurley and Robert
Klatte worthy set decoration by George
Milo son art direction by Tom Monaghan
set decoration by Lionel couch is it to
a small planet art direction by Hal
Ferrara and Walter Tyler set decoration
by Sam comer and Arthur cram and the
winner is July the apartment dr. Connors
excepting for Alexander kroner is Edward
G Boyle
congratulations mr Boyle thank you very
much thank you very much and I'm sure
Alex would wish me to say thank you for
him to those nominated for best
achievement in art direction and set
decoration for a color picture are
similar art direction by George W Davis
and Addison air set decoration by Henry
grace Hugh hunt and Arthur Siegel
it started at maples art direction by
Hal Ferrara and Roland Anderson set
decoration by Sam comer and re Gabreski
art direction by Ted Hayworth set
decoration by William Cameron Spartacus
art direction by Alexander galitsin and
Eric or bomb set decoration by Russell a
Gausman and Julia Heron sunrise at
Campobello art direction by Edward
fidelity set decoration by George James
Hopkins the winner is thank you
Spartacus
congratulations we want to thank all the
artists and crafts on that help us for
this picture this art this award
represents the culmination of a man's
life and his career in the movie
industry I can think of no greater
achievement for a man Thank You Ella has
my diction coach
you